wir sind in maryland six flags
eigentlich ein freizeitpark ist jetzt
auch im zentrum fast 4000 menschen
kommen heute dran
geimpft wird im vorbeifahren im auto
auch die 74 jährige sohn hervor finger
bekommt ihre zweite und letzte corona
impfung ihr mann joe hat das schon
hinter sich und fährt sie ich frage mich
ob sie hier auch leute auf dem fahrrad
im bringt impfen wie am fließband so das
motto der usa so viele wie möglich so
schnell wie möglich doch nur wer sich
schnell genug kümmern zukommt auch dran
sohn hatte es zigmal versucht doch immer
war sie zu spät
ihr neffe hat ihr schließlich geholfen
er hat mir eine nachricht geschickt und
gesagt tante joan der freizeitpark
vergibt termine dann bin ich an meinem
pc gras total nervös und hab meinen mann
gebeten mir zuzuschauen weil ich angst
hatte einen fehler zu machen
für frank ist selbst ernannter wegziehen
hunter also impfstoff jäger er hilft
menschen an termine zu kommen postet
ständig neue infos online bei facebook
kostenlos
wir schauen dass die die einen termin
wollen auch ein bekommen um möglichst
viele impfungen in möglichst viele arme
das ist unser ziel
wir geben menschen tipps und tricks wie
sie selbst an ein termin kommen und
machen für die die das nicht selbst
können welche aus jetzt heißt das 15
minuten warten option den impfstoff auch
verträgt
die usa hatten stets die höchsten corona
zahlen jetzt gehören sie beim impfen
plötzlich zu den vorzeige ländern rund
zwei millionen menschen werden täglich
geimpft amerika impft überall im
baseball-stadion auf rennstrecken in
disneyland neben achterbahn mit band und
musik und inzwischen sogar nachts und
auch in apotheken wird geimpft impfstoff
ist da bereits zu beginn der pandemie
investierte ex-präsident trump und
bestellte enorme mengen von moderner und
bei und ex-präsident beiden orderte noch
einmal nach durch ein schnelleres not
zulassungsverfahren ist nun auch schon
der impfstoff von johnson johnson auf
dem markt die regierung verteilt ihn an
die staaten und die bringen ihn unter
die leute viele stars geben sich als
vorbilder in den meisten staaten kommt
schon dran wir 65 und älter ist
vorerkrankungen wie asthma und diabetes
hat in schulen oder im supermarkt
arbeitet und nicht nur das der
supermarkt selbst ist hier zum im
zentrum geworden niemand muss zu hause
sitzen und auf die impfung warten wie so
häufig gilt in den usa hands-on jeder
ist selbst seines glückes schmied
das ehepaar voigt hat sich erst online
einen termin ergattert lässt sich nun
die zweite spritze verpassen
anschließend machen sie den
wocheneinkauf
wir haben gesagt wir sind rein gelaufen
bin fertig gebaut ist ein bisschen und
dann bist du draußen ist alles an einem
tag großartig
die beiden können ihr glück kaum fassen
und versuchen andere mit ihrer euphorie
anzustecken
haben sie ihre schon bekommen nein ich
habe angst in den usa sind es besonders
oft benachteiligte schwarze die nicht
geimpft werden oder die misstrauisch
sind sie bleiben beim im wettlauf auf
der strecke das will dr steven thomas
ändern durch aufklärung in friseursalons
für ihn genau der richtige ort um über
die imf risiken zu informieren wenn es
um gesundheitsthemen im allgemeinen und
cupid im speziellen geht muss du
menschen dort treffen wo sie sind und
leute einspannen den bereits vertraut
wird und schwarzen friseurin wird hier
besonders vertraut mike entfernt nicht
nur haarspitzen sondern auch im skepsis
ich habe gemischte gefühle menschen aus
meiner familie haben die im fonds schon
und daraufhin fieber bekommen und
mussten ins krankenhaus
deshalb bin ich mir unsicher
ich werde mich impfen lassen wir müssen
ein zeichen setzen als schwarze weil
unsere gemeinden besonders hart
getroffen ist
die totenzahlen sind sehr hoch deshalb
müssen wir zeigen wie man die krankheit
bekämpfen kann
der einzige weg ist durch die impfung so
bringen die usa impfung nun direkt in
gefährdete gemeinden wie in portimao
jeder bekommt eine kostenfrei auch ohne
versicherung
die kirche von pastor karte wurde in nur
wenigen tagen zum im zentrum umgebaut
lasst das impfen beginn impfen dort wo
sie eigentlich zu hause sind heiraten
ihre kinder taufen lassen lachen feiern
und beten
wir können besonders viele menschen
erreichen weil wir sie kennen und sie
uns ich fühle mich wohler das hier
machen zu lassen ich war so froh als der
pastor das hier möglich gemacht hat das
fühlt sich sicherer als anderswo
siehst du das ich bin froh weil ich erst
zweifel hatte aber dann dachte ich
lieber sicher als zu spät
hier hoffen sie dass sie so bald wieder
sonntags zusammen singen können und auch
john hat ihre impfung inzwischen hinter
sich alles lief gut sie ist erleichtert
das gibt uns freiheit die möglichkeit
wieder mit der familie zusammen zu sein
die familie ist das wichtigste in meinem
leben einfach mal wieder mit meiner
schwester und meinen schwager zusammen
zu essen und menschen zu umarmen
als erstes bekommen natürlich die
wegziehen hunter beschied sie haben es
möglich gemacht wieder ein bisschen mehr
leben für john und ihren mann joe